hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
gonna answer a question from one of our
readers whose name is Petrus they wrote
insane I've opened a consulting business
and assisting students with their
assignments tutoring research projects
I'm running it from home because I don't
have enough funds to run the classroom
in an office I want your assistance on
how to grow this business I have a
passion to assist students who can't
help themselves with your assistance
I've become a greater consultant so
thanks for the question Petrus great
question and I applaud you for starting
small starting out of your home it's
it's easy to spend money right anybody
can go spend money you can take out all
your savings and go get an office and
get a classroom and spend spend spend
and quickly be out of business because
you spent all your money and you have
nothing coming in so I always recommend
as much as possible to start small
bringing customers slowly build that up
and then as you see that something's
working you can invest more money into
it so I hate spending money till I make
you money so you're ready on the right
path with the right mindset that's great
it's also awesome to hear your passion
for a lot of entrepreneurs start a
business just trying to make money and
they don't have a strong passion for it
you really have to love what you do
because you're gonna go through some
major heartbreak and hurdles before you
reach success so you got to have that
passion for it to stick with it in terms
of your business I don't know what level
of students you're selling to it's the
student marketing can be really hard to
sell to because love them don't have the
money so you might end up trying to sell
to the parents if they're younger
students for shirts it's to the parents
it's a slightly different customer what
I try to figure out is you could have
your private one-on-one students which
is great and they'll probably be some
upper limit on how much you could charge
for it you might want to consider going
into getting groups of students together
so it reduces the cost for them and I
can also make you a little bit more
money so how that can even be out of
your home or could even be out of a
coffee shop if you get three or four
students and then slowly try to build
that up for students it's great because
it can be repeat business right so
how long somebody says 54 but if they're
going through university you know it
could be four or five years if they go
through high school again you know three
four years going through that so they
could stay with you for a long time you
have to show that you care about them
that you're providing outstanding
service and a lot of times it'll grow
through word of mouth which is an
awesome way to be able to build your
business but you have to give them
something to talk about
right you have to deliver results for
them they have to be seen improvements
and they have to really like coming to
you and feeling like you're really
solving a problem for them it's great
you have the passion for it that
definitely helps if you find ways to
really go beyond above and beyond
provide awesome service you're gonna get
them talking to their friends to their
parents and coming back to you to keep
signing up with you and you know
bringing their there Collier they're
their classmates along with them so
that's that's one way to start growing
it you'll find that with a lot of
service businesses like this there is
some upper end that you could charge for
your prices and at some point you will
be tapped out so it's are you
comfortable building this business as a
one-man show and it's just you and you
have your roster of thirty students I
don't know how many you can support a
lot of that is easy to grow through
word-of-mouth you know you get some
students they tell their friends you
might do some you know fliers at the
schools but that is usually not too
challenging to build up if you provide
in a really good service
it may take it you know a number of
months to get it going but the costs are
low because you're running out at home
it's a service based business that's
just your time so you don't have to
spend a lot of money to build this
business up you'll get to the point
where you're tapped out you know you
can't handle more students yourself you
can try increasing your prices which is
a great strategy and the more you can
brand yourself as an expert and have a
method so instead of just saying I'm
gonna be tutoring you and help you with
your assignments you say you know I have
this eight step process that I go
through and that's how you separate
yourself from all the other tutors out
there so the the petrous way is to go
through these eight steps and the more
you can brand yourself and have that
methodology the easier it's going to be
for you to be seen as a greater expert
in a better
than everybody else so you need to find
that way to separate and differentiate
yourself from all the other tutors out
there so that will help you start
increasing your prices but you still be
at the point where you're doing
everything yourself so the question
becomes how to expand beyond that so
your couple options one could be the
group classes so you have multiple
people in a room and two could be to
have a tutor under you so is there a way
to build this business and build enough
margin into it so that it could run
without you being there so you know
you're charging X for your services and
you have a tutor who you've hired we
were charging you know less - and you're
making the difference on the profit and
that's a very common challenge a lot of
service based businesses it's a great
way to get started because you're making
money and you're not spending a lot of
money where products you have physical
costs but it can be really hard to
expand it because it's still selling
your time for money so once you get past
that point you may get frustrated and
you want to think about how do I build
this beyond myself how can I build a
model where I have enough revenue coming
in to be able to support another tutor
even part-time so that I can build this
business and continue to grow it now you
may not have that ambition it may be
fine you know you want to have your
roster of students it's always going to
be you your one-man show and that's
great and there's nothing wrong with
that really the secret to making that
work is just provide an awesome service
getting the word of mouth going find in
a way to separate yourself from all the
other tutors and doing some light
marketing even in the form of just some
fliers that's a school and you should
get enough people over a number of
months to want to sign up with you and
stick with you right if the students
aren't staying with you then there's a
problem with your service but once you
get a student hopefully they stay with
you for a year or longer because you're
providing awesome service and they'll
tell their friends and you'll keep
getting more people coming in the bigger
challenge comes and trying to expand the
business beyond yourself and building a
model where you can support having
somebody under you and still be able to
make enough money to support yourself so
hopefully it gives you a few things to
think about
I love again that you're starting small
starting from home keep the cost low and
that
you're really passionate about this and
and hopefully willing to go through all
the hurdles that it's going to take to
get that business to the next step so
thanks for watching everybody if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below makes me to do more of these
for you and if you have a comment about
this video or you have a question about
your own business feel free to leave it
below I always read those I love seeing
them and I'd hopefully can make a video
for you as well if you have a question
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you